bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de la voie est libre pour une
émission exceptionnelle aujourd'hui
en effet nous recevons une seule invitée
marie-guite dufay
bonjour madame vous êtes donc la
nouvelle présidente socialiste de la
nouvelle région bourgogne franche comté
et vous avez été élu ce lundi vous
téléspectateurs vous pouvez réagir au
cours de cette émission
grâce au réseau social twitter avec le
hashtag lvl bft bfc c'est à dire la voix
est libre
bourgogne franche comté et avec moi pour
mener cet entretien lilian melet
aujourd'hui
bonjour 4 et nous allons revenir sur
cette journée particulière de lundi avec
votre élection à la présidence vous
allez nous dire aussi ce que vous voulez
faire
mais avant nous avons très envie de vous
entendre sur cette campagne électorale
très particulière une nouvelle région
des sondages défavorables pendant un
certain temps et des attentats quelques
semaines avant le premier tour
marie-guite dufay d'abord on a envie de
vous demander il y a un an de sa
qu'alliez vous faire dans cette galère
cette cette campagne aller au bout de ce
que j'avais fait il me semble est
irresponsable de ne pas aller au bout de
ne pas défendre cette conception de la
grande région mois kim était fortement
investi dans le projet de la grande
région
ça ne me semblait pas responsable et
donc c'est cela qui m'a guidé avec la
conscience que nous avions fait un
travail correct au niveau cette région
et j'avais envie de le faire connaître
mais c'est vraiment l'idée de défendre
la grande région qui m'a poussé le jour
des attentats
comment est ce que vous les apprenez et
quel est votre premier sentiment votre
première j'avais des réactions vous
pensez à quoi
on n'a rien c'est la sidération fait
l'anéantissement j'ai même pas pensé à
moi et à la campagne je pense que c'est
quelques heures plus tard j'ai dit mais
au fait on est en campagne
non franchement la première action du
pas du tout pensé à me projeter par
rapport à la campagne et honnêtement
quand j'ai commencé à réaliser
j'ai entendu que il y avait vraiment une
hypothèse de suspendre les élections
ça m'allait très bien quoi c'était
impossible de faire autrement
il ya une forme de malentendu entre
suspensions de campagne d'une semaine
pour vous pour beaucoup de candidats
socialistes en région la volonté du
parti socialiste au niveau national
avait claude bartolone de suspens plus
longtemps et on a entendu la droite
pendant cette campagne sans vraiment
oser le dire mais laisse entendre que la
suspension campagne vous arrangerait
parce que pendant ce temps là on était
dans l'émotion nationale
excusez moi ça c'est vraiment
politiciens non comment pouvions-nous
aller au devant des gens avec nous ou
nos préoccupations régionales
moi je me suis battu pour les
préoccupations des jeunes alors qu'on
avait en tête que la question nationale
puis la question mondiale parce que tout
cela nous nous relie au monde aux
terroristes et aux victimes pack de
paris mais aussi du liban de jordanie de
du sénégal
enfin donc non c'était c'était
impossible comment la politique quel
moment vous vous dites il faut qu'on y
retourne et comment on parle aux gens et
est ce qu'on parle différemment aux gens
de ça faisait huit mois déjà vous vous
parliez aux bourguignons et au franc
comtois donc est ce qu'on fait à ce
moment là mais on parle on parle de la
république
on parle de la façon dont on peut lui
faire du bien à cette république qui est
notre bien commun et moi j'ai redémarré
la campagne avec l'appui extrêmement
fort du président de mon comité de
soutien jean noël jeanneney dont je
trouvais qu'il était vraiment la
personne idoine pour repartir parce que
historiens parce que profond humaniste
parce que aux hommes politiques
aussi ayant une expérience de la
politique et il nous a aidés lors de
notre première union fut à chenôve c'est
à ce niveau que j'ai redémarré la
campagne et donc il ya eu beaucoup de
monde je peux pas dire que c'était un
meeting c'était quelque chose de
totalement différent et où on s'est
parlé pour voir comment effectivement
demain il fallait redémarrer voir ce que
vous alliez finalement à ce moment là
mais vous savez petit à petit mois ce
qui m'est apparu c'est que la république
elle avait besoin de cours à elle avait
besoin de fraternité
liberté égalité fraternité moi je suis
reparti sur cette question de la
fraternité en inventant pas puisque au
fronton de notre programme nous avions
déjà mis et cette valeur et qu'est ce
qui sert cette valeur dans les
compétences de la région c'est la
culture c'est le vivre ensemble c'est
l'engagement associatif et j'avais dit
ça malgré les contraintes budgétaires
dans lesquelles nous sommes ça ne doit
pas être une variable d'ajustement
ça doit pas baisser je promets pas rond
et merveilles 1 mais ils disent ça ne
doit pas être une variable d'ajustement
la division a commencé en vous demandons
donc la position dans laquelle vous
étiez il ya un an
est-ce que aussi vous vous dites que
vous avez dû relancer votre campagne
est-ce que ça a été difficile de
s'imposer face à des socialistes
bourguignons qui eux ont l'habitude de
gérer des questions politiques en
interne au parti socialiste
je ne suis pas le sentiment d'avoir une
difficulté avec les socialistes plus
bourguignon que franc comtois jeunes
avaient aussi avec les francs comtois
sont encore là la difficulté que j'ai
eue mais la difficulté mais je pense que
je suis pas seul je pense qu à droite
aussi
c'est vraiment de sentir l'indifférence
totale
c'est terrible c'est terrible de sentir
cette indifférence de voir les militants
venir me voir pour me dire on sait plus
comment faire parce que on va distribuer
on va dans les lieux habituels on
distribue et puis bah oui on distribue
les gens traînent on n'arrive pas à
amorcer les débats nous disent nous
prenions même pas partie de la
différence totale d'un différent voilà
c'est l'indifférence
cette indifférence j'ai trop pour moi
c'était une chape de plomb et j'ai tout
de suite vu un résultat du premier tour
ben le lien entre cette indifférence et
puis le résultat du premier tour
l'abstention il paraît des attentats
lect alors est ce que vous sentez un
moment où après ça sachant justement par
rapport à cette indifférence
parce que les us qu'on sait que jusqu
aux attentes à un certain nombre de
sondages donner des projections et puis
que les choses ont changé et façon
chiffrée
à ce moment là est-ce que ça
correspondait aussi pour les gens à
quelque chose ou est ce que c'était que
les attentats c'était tellement fort que
toutes les cartes terrebonne qui coûtait
personnellement moi je n'ai pas sentie
différente pour moi c'était encore plus
difficile de vaincre ce mur
d'indifférence
mais je crois qu'ils étaient déjà
installés avant les attentats donc il
était là et probablement que
l'indifférence d'avant les attentats
n'est pas la même que la différence
d'après à la pour faire leur âge ou de
l'indifférence à elle est là et je pense
que les attentats ont nourri ya et
renforcer encore cette indifférence
alors au premier tour donc vous le
disiez tout à l'heure forte abstention
front national créé au vous réagissez
comme on vous a vu dans un reportage
qu'on a diffusé vous ne croyez m'en pas
les chiffres qui vous sont communiquées
mais ça a été que c'est compliqué parce
que pour le temps d'avoir les vrais
résultats
j'ai été obligé de réagir en n'ayant pas
connaissance des résultats globaux donc
c'est pour ça que j'étais un peu dans
l'instabilité
quand j'ai eu le résultat global finale
et c'est monsieur pressée qui me l'a
donné c'est normal ça qui téléphona à
des candidats pour donner le résultat
soit on lui dit j'ai été recruté prison
avait téléphoné aussi dans la voiture
auparavant vu donner des résultats non
nancy lorraine j'étais pressé on va dans
la voiture quand je suis arrivé est
arrivé à la préfecture mon premier
réflexe a été de voir le préfet donc il
me donne les résultats avant que je
puisse répondre aux journalistes qui me
demandaient à quelle minute et à kehl
secondes vous vous désister
voilà parce que c'était ça vous vous
excusez moi j'avais vu j'avais vu deux
choses
j'avais vu qu'il y avait une petite
réserve de voix décevante par rapport à
ce que j'attendais une grosse déception
c'est que les alliés naturels
communistes et verts ne soit pas avec
nous mais il y avait une réserve de voix
alors que je voyais quand même que chez
mon challenger
il n'y avait pas cette réserve uvre
alain sauval et il n'y avait pas cette
réserve de voix et je me suis dit je l'
ai senti quand même aujourd'hui dans
l'état du pays où nous sommes je pense
que l'idée que le front national arrive
en première position est quelque chose
qui doit susciter un sursaut républicain
et j'ai misé sur ce site sursaut
républicain
mais à un moment donné vous
10 je retire ma candidature voilà est-ce
que vous y étiez préparé est ce qu'il y
avait un seuil en deçà duquel et le
voilà dans votre tête
on ne vous l'avait pas dit à ce moment
là mais vous pourrez peut-être oublié
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un sage m'étais
dit que si je pense si c'est pas les 21%
g9 tirer et vous aviez préparé ce moment
vous étiez projeté dans ce moment sans
vraiment se projeter parce que vous avez
quand vous êtes dans une élection vous
vous projetez plutôt dense qui va vous
permettre d'avancer puis de gagner un
don vous vous installez pas trop dans la
déprime
mais je peux vous le dire parce que j'ai
eu un échange je me souviens avec mon
fils dans les heures qui avaient précédé
puis connais pas trop à toutes les
questions politiques et puissante et qui
avait sujet puis il m'avait dit bon
malheur finalement concrètement c'est
quoi c'est à partir de quel chiffrage
est lui prêt ce qui m'avait poussée dans
mes retranchements
j'avais 10 21 bon voilà donc là c'était
pas 21 j'étais très proche
françois sauvadet et je voyais bien que
j'avais des réserves qu'ils n'avaient
pas et qu'il fallait compter sur ce
sursaut républicain
je peux pas vous dire que c'était
extrêmement sûre de moi mais il ya un
moment les combats si vous les engagés
pas vous voulez gagner pas et là je vais
quand même eu ce sentiment qu'ils
avaient un combat à mener et que
contrairement à paca et au nord pas de
calais c'était à lagos à la main à le
mener nord pas de calais est pas cassé
la droite qui a fait barrage au front
national la me suis dit
effectivement on est la région où ce
doit être la gauche est ce que vous avez
été déçu par l'attitude de la droite qui
n'arrêtait pas de marteler ses nous
puisque nous sommes deuxièmes qui
pouvons faire barrage au fn
ça fait mal ça fait mal parce que c'est
faux à ces fausses et voilà ça fait mal
vous at on dit quoi
2 de la draft cette attitude non non non
mais toute façon je me moi j'ai passé
cette élection a jamais trop me poser de
questions par rapport à la droite a
toujours me poser des questions sur ce
que je fais est ce que ça a du sens
comment je me comporte avec mes alliés
naturels
comment je vais chercher sur la base de
mes valeurs
les citoyens voilà lilian revient sur
l'élection de lundi de victoire demain
et guides du 7 au deuxième tour c'est
vrai la bourgogne franche comté une
nouvelle région l'a dit il a donc fallu
attendre ce lundi pour la journée
d'installation l'élection d'un président
est une très longue journée
encore un peu mouvementée avant d'en
parler on va regarder ce résumé de la
journée du lundi 4 janvier 2016
marie-guite dufay fait son entrée dans
l'hémicycle ce matin et donne aussitôt
le ton
le tellement de travail à faire il
faut rester cool
oui pour faire les choses les taudis
place 5 60 ans a toujours fait appel sur
scène et au boulot et c'est le prg le
parti radical de gauche qui va lui
donner du boulot dans l'escalier elle
croit justement l'un des deux et du prg
à ce moment là
problème les deux élus prg ne veulent
pas voter du feu au premier tour la
réunion du groupe ps au premier étage
est tendue ça se passe comment là et
bien ça se passe que on organise la
tendance un fonctionnement du groupe
les commissions les relations entre le
père j'ai des relations avec le prg et
leur espace comment là on n'en saura pas
davantage et à 14h30
arrive le moment tant attendu les 100
conseillers régionaux vote pour élire
leur président aucun candidat pour la
droite le front national présentes
sophie montel et le ps marie-guite dufay
au premier tour quoique
marie-guite dufay n'obtient que 49 voix
la majorité est à 51
il lui manque donc a priori les deux
voies du prj pour être élu
serre après une suspension de séance à
deuxième tour est organisé
les socialistes semblent moins tendu il
compte les voix ouf
cinquante-et-une marie-guite dufay
socialiste est donc élue c'est la
première présidente du tout nouveau
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté du feu avant de parler cuisine
politique que le cheveu deuxième tour un
mot quand même sur l'émotion on vous a
vu ému au moment de l'annoncé il ya des
d'autres images quoi débit dans la
presse un moment donné on vous a vu
encore plus ému dans cette journée en
écoutant les discours c'est fort ou pas
ce moment là la fin de cette journée
caen quand on dit mardi du fait était du
président c'est pas poli je peux vous
dire le contraire m'aurait lieu peut
bien je vais pas vous dire le contraire
petitement et puis ce qui est compliqué
c'est qu'on soit en plein d'émotions qui
quand même temps on se sent au regard
des donc il faut mépriser tout ça va y
avoir un de parole a prononcé donc c'est
compliqué de maîtriser les motions moi
je sais pas bien d'électriser donc la
maîtrise bien un bon ben alors vous avez
pleuré quand vous avez pleuré quand si
vous avez pleuré
vous avez pleuré à moins donné dans
cette journée non non j'ai pas pleurer
dans la dans la journée soit pas dans
l'hémicycle peut être après non non j'ai
pas pleurer dans la journée non c'est
plutôt pleurer le soir 2
la victoire là c'était autre chose on
revient sur ce dont catherine parler
dans le reportage sur cette journée on
est un peu étonné de voir que finalement
il n'y avait pas de d'accord cimenté
total fermer pour une élection 51 50 et
une voix tout de suite
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé est ce que
il ya des élus qu'on fait de la
surenchère est ce que les bourguignons
ne vous avait pas tout dit l'offre
dissensions avec le prg
qu'est ce que c'est pas sinon je pense
que le psg est effectivement bon pignon
que je le connais peu et qu'il me
connaît peu je pense que c'est cela et
que il a découvert que je ne sais des
passes sur l'essentiel et moi j'ai voulu
le lui faire comprendre dès le lendemain
de l'élection que sur l'essentiel à
savoir la constitution d'un groupe pour
deux personnes ça n'avait pas de sens et
que je respectais sa volonté de de bien
montrer son identité mais que ça passait
par tout à fait autre chose et d'autres
signes et d'autres actions que la
constitution d'un groupe
donc pour moi la messe était dite à
partir du moment où j'ai dit qu'il n'y
aurait pas de groupe et pour lui non
donc nous sommes allés jusqu'à cet
épisode qui est triste vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur parce que franchement je
pense qu'on a à donner de la politique
une autre image que cette image de de
dissension et puis que notre groupe
socialiste il a besoin de solidarité le
défi qui nous attend est immense et donc
moi je j'en appel à cette solidarité
mais mais bon c'est pas été entendu ceci
dit je n'ai pas cédé sur l'essentiel est
par contre nous avons trouvé les
éléments d'un compromis
ça veut dire que le rapport de force
vous estimez que vous c'est monsieur
molines aux qu'il a imposées et que vous
vous en êtes bien tirer bat nous avons
trouvé un compromis
voilà la famille socialiste s'est réuni
à les familles ça se divisaient souvent
et donc là la famille elle était divisée
elle s'est retrouvée et l'essentiel
c'est qu'elle se retrouve pour le
travail à faire maintenant
le paradoxe est que vous avez parlé des
partenaires tout de suite des
communistes d'europe écologie dès le
soir de votre élection mais cela suppose
yoga son bras dessus bras dessous à la
natalité sur la berge et marché derrière
alors que c'est eux qui ont deux élus et
qui vont vous amener ces deux voies mais
pour moi il était tellement dans la
majorité c'est pas des alliés naturels
c'est la majorité donc pour moi il n'y
avait pas de problème à ce moment pour
eux manifestement il y en avait un petit
peu plus vous avez beaucoup dit que
enfin vous avez beaucoup rendu hommage
europe écologie et au parti communiste
et vous avez dit il faudra qu'on trouve
une solution travailler ensemble c'est
vraiment possible on sait juste des
paroles de consolation
je suis pas tellement connu pour dire
des paroles et ne pas les tenir
par contre je ne sais pas quel mois des
modalités nous allons trouver
donc on va se donner du temps pour se
retrouver là on est quand même en pleine
organisation et c'est un peu compliqué
donc je leur ai demandé qu'on se donne
un petit peu de temps qu'on se retrouve
d'ici la fin du mois de janvier début du
mois de février pour voir je sais pas il
faut qu'on invente toute façon sur plein
de choses il faut qu'on avance
ça va vous donner les mains plus libres
ou ou peut-être pas finalement bac 2 pas
dans une majorité de voir tenir compte
de l'avis des écologistes et des
communistes c'est parfois pratique
d'avoir des partenaires qui vont aider à
faire passer certaines réformes ou de la
bulgarie battu mais moi je le regrette
moi je le regrette mais je le regrette
par rapport à la haye la dynamique dit
des uns parce que les bases pas possible
pour le rapport de force
néanmoins je le regrette par rapport à
la dynamique dit j'ai une majorité avec
les avec les vertes ont pas avec les
communistes
c'est vrai qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'essence beaucoup de frictions beaucoup
de rapport de force comme vous dite
catherine mais pour moi ce qui compte
c'est quand même les idées pour
lesquelles on se bat et puis qu'on veut
faire avancer et franchement ça a
toujours été gagnant ça enrichit notre
rôle notre programme et notre façon de
voir
donc c'est dommage parce que je trouve
que l'action publique est tellement
compliqué aujourd'hui que si on s'y met
pas tous ensemble on se prive de quelque
chose et là manifestement la composante
vert
la composante communiste elle apporte
des éléments qui sont importants donc je
regrette c'est pour ça que je veux
garder le contact
dans votre discours lundi vous avez vous
avez parlé des collectivités
territoriales en général vous n'avez pas
nommé les départements françois sauvadet
donc votre opposant aux côtés régional
vous l'a reproché c'est un oubli ou ou
ses volailles vers ben non c'est ni un
oubli ni un acte volontaire quand je
parle des collectivités ce sont les
départements et ce sont les les
agglomérations sont les partenaires
naturels de la région
elle va me manquer le premier acte sera
de réunir tous ses partenaires justement
sur la question qui nous a divisés sont
utilisés pendant la campagne de ce que
pour moi c'est pas un sujet politique
c'est un sujet d'action publique la
question du numérique
ce sera probablement une des premières
réunions qui nous amènera département
salut à grever ravir avec les huit
présidents des départements de
franche-comté bourgogne
oui voilà et le fait que tu en es 6 qui
se bat à droite et seulement 2 qui
résonnait sanaa ça n'a rien à voir là ça
ne compte pas ça françois sauvadet ce
n'était pas une menace en creux qui
voulait dire je vous rappelle qu'il ya
six départements survie qui sont à
droite et qu'on va pas vous rendrez vous
l'avez compris comme ça que nous on est
mauvais esprit mais non non non non non
non moi je veux pas rentrer là dedans et
je pense que françois sauvadet n'est pas
là dedans il peut pas être là dedans
ce sont les départements qu'ils soient
de droite ou de gauche maintenant que
l'élection est passée qui sont avec la
région qui est de gauche certes mais là
aussi il faut qu'on trouve
il faut qu'on trouve des déséquilibres
décalage des façons de travailler
ensemble nous travaillons beaucoup moins
que par le passé avec les départements
sur la question économique puisque les
transferts de compétences renforce la
région avec les ados 1
mais il ya tout sens de l'aménagement du
territoire orthézien sur le transport il
ya tout le sens des transports des
transferts de compétences avec les
transports scolaires notamment
donc là ce sont des partenaires naturels
nous amener à la suite de cette émission
qui est vieilli transition parfait les
cinq ans et trois mois qui restent avant
de nous dire comment vous concevez drôle
de la région reçoivent aux priorités on
va d'abord on en parlait avec françois
sauvadet écouter un mot de votre
opposition qui s'est exprimé lundi lors
de cette session les écoutes j'ai
désormais au pied du mur et du mur il ya
une véritable urgence sociale économique
agir concrètement
je ne pourrais pas continuer de nier la
réalité des difficultés que connaît
notre nouvelle région
comme vous l'avez fait régulièrement je
dis simplement ces derniers mois j'ai
pas demandé revers de main ah les petits
arrangements entre amis sont encore à
l'ordre du jour
mais rassurez vous madame la présidente
les élus déry les républicains sauront
vous apporter un soutien franc et massif
durant cette mandature
comme ils l'ont fait d'ailleurs depuis
2004 car sur le fond entre le parti
socialiste et les républicains et lui
dit vous êtes d'accord sur tout car ce
qui a provoqué certaines réactions du
front national c'est que vous avez entre
autres vous avez proposé de la
présidence d'une commission à la droite
et pas au front national
vous justifiez comme en sachant qu'il y
a qu un siège d'écart entre ces deux
gros à écouter pour moi il ya quand même
une différence
une ligne qui ne peut pas être franchies
entre la droite et l'extrême droite
et donc ma position est vraiment d'être
dans une posture de recherche de
compromis sur les grands sujets cette
culture du compromis qui manque tant
elle est nécessaire et puis la recherche
de la transparence aussi est là donc la
question des finances pour moi c'est
vraiment dire au parti républicain est
bien la transparence est là et donc il
faut que chacun s'empare de cette
première oui mais quand vous parlez de
compromis vous faites un peu le jeu du
front national qui dit ump sous les
républicains ps même combat
moi je pense qu on est dans une
situation où c'est tellement difficile
aujourd'hui de trouver les bonnes
réponses à tous ceux qui doutent
de tous à tous ceux qui sont inquiets
que il faut vraiment unir toutes les
toutes les compétences toutes les bonnes
volontés et moi je pars du principe
qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté la gauche car
ils ont d'autres comtés la droite 14 et
que nous avons des valeurs qui vous
oppose mais nous avons aussi un souci de
l'intérêt général et qui aujourd'hui
doit prévaloir ça veut pas dire qu'on va
se retrouver surtout bien sûr que non ça
veut pas dire qu'on va lâcher nos
valeurs
non mais vous savez sur la question
économique
comment booste l'activité économique
dans notre pays
ce serait dommage qu'on travaille pas
plus ensemble le contexte que des
attentats ont fait que ces élections
est ce que ça vous donne un sentiment de
responsabilité plus fort que peut-être
dans une élection précédente
et puis le fait aussi que face à vouillé
pour la première fois presque autant de
conseillers régionaux du front national
que de la droite
ça c'est plutôt ça qui me donne ce
sentiment de responsabilité
c'est à la fois d'avoir constaté
l'abstention très forte dans le pays
puis de voir le poids très important de
l'extrême droite
et puis effectivement de voir que nous
sommes en tripartisme un tiers un tiers
un tiers
donc du coup ça me donne effectivement
ce sentiment d'être obligé de voir
comment travailler en dialoguant avec
des forces qui ne partage pas
complètement nos valeurs mais qui
apporte aussi des choses et aujourd'hui
je nous avons à répondre à tous ceux qui
votent extrême droite qui choisissent
l'extrême droite on je repense à cette
phrase de fabuleuses je crois c'était
dans les années 80 3 qui disait le front
national au moment où il émerger c'est
une mauvaise réponse à des bonnes
questions et on en est toujours là et il
faut qu'on arrive à trouver les bonnes
réponses mais ça c'était il ya trente
ans visiblement damas est toujours là
c'est terrible
vous n'avez pas trouvé forcément les
réponses aux questions très concrètes
le conseil régional a des représentants
dans tous les établissements scolaires
type lycée est ce que vous allez envoyer
des représentants front national dans
certains établissements c'est une
question oui je vous la pose mais c'est
une question de vérification faite pour
qu on les travaille avant qu'on y
réponde
donc c'est l'objet du travail de ma
majorité actuellement je consulte sur
cette question je consulte beaucoup je
consulte un comité enseignante notamment
parce que je sens beaucoup de beaucoup
d'inquiétude
il ya un débat parti qui a été élu et
qui représentent un tiers des électeurs
ben il est là effectivement et on ne
peut pas ne pas traiter avec lui et puis
en même temps c'est un parti qui
véhiculent des idées qui prononcé dans
une enceinte scolaire au sein d'une
communauté éducative font mal donc la
réponse elle sera le 21 21 janvier et
vous n'avez pas d'avis tranché sur la
question pour le moment vous voyez bien
remédier à leur sujet comme ça on peut
pas avoir d'avis tranché ça fait partie
de ces nécessités trouver des nouvelles
réponses on peut pas répondre par une
possible il faut répondre intelligemment
et l'intelligence elle demande un petit
peu de temps on continue on va bien sûr
dans la deuxième partie d'émission par
les programmes est ce que vous voulez
faire mais d'abord le premier point des
trois axes que vous aviez évoqué vous
avez évoqué la grande région vous avez
évoqué l'économie et vous avez évoqué on
va dire l'écologie ce sens large mais
sur la grande région vous avez dit en
fait il faut la construire
comment vous voulez la construire la
faire exister d'abord vous êtes rendu
compte qu'elle existait pas encore
vraiment et il faut faire quoi des
symboles tout de suite des actes forts
il ya 1 minute 30 là dans la première
partie on en parlera dans la deuxième
partie vous inquiétez pas c'est un
travail de longue haleine c'est pas tout
de suite moi je suis pas fou je suis pas
pour les coups médiatiques
je pense que c'est vraiment un travail
de très longue haleine ce rassemblement
de culture de cultures différentes
il ya effectivement beaucoup différence
yahoo 6
antilles pendant tout au long de la
campagne une envie une appétence 1 à se
rencontrer à échanger les points forts
entre les uns et les autres le nom les
choses comme ça c'est important ou pas
oui mais bourgogne franche comté c'est
un mal d'ailleurs faites votre choix il
y aura une diffusion puisque
effectivement la loi nous y oblige un
don qui aura alors à débat 1 mais
j'avoue que je vous j'avoue que par
rapport à ceux se chauffe des identités
and que l'on voit bien chacun s'y
retrouve c'est beau pourquoi une franche
comté alors le fait que parmi les
vice-présidents il y en ait neuf
bourguignon et seulement six francomtois
est ce qu on vous en a parlé quand vous
êtes revenu à besançon jamais jamais
jamais valeur cela fait l'affairé contre
seulement mais votre seulement il
devrait pas exister
vous avez là un rapport de 9 à 6 quels
rapports de la démographie entre la
bourgogne et la franche comté et le
seulement il n'est pas adapté car
regardez les compétences qui sont
attribués aux francs comtois ne sont pas
légères l'économie la formation les
fonds européens
l'aménagement du territoire de dire
seulement l'agriculture l'agriculture
les aviez oublié donc que la délégation
de l'agriculture
c'est pourquoi je leur criais je la cite
allez on va s'arrêter là pour le moment
marie-guite dufay
on se retrouve